we're taking a live look at mccarran
airport where it has been a challenging
afternoon flights have been delayed and
the problems with southwest airlines
still are happening and the wind is not
making anything any better 8 news now
reporter madison kimbrel live at the
airport with the very latest madison
so it's definitely picked up here we're
seeing more passengers in the baggage
claim area as flights are coming in but
the frustration continues as wait times
for delayed flights reach one to two
hours
over the weekend southwest cited air
traffic control issues along with
weather but many passengers said they
felt it was a cruise shortage issue a
possible factor could be the southwest
vaccine mandate that was put into effect
recently causing what some are saying is
an internal strike among some southwest
employees today over 300 southwest
flights have been canceled nationwide
and up to 1800 throughout the entire
weekend i'm waiting on my family right
now it's like an hour delay from ontario
california to be honest i was a little
worried i was like oh heck no when i
when i went to work i didn't see the
weather that way but when i came back
and i knew that their flight was coming
in at three the cancellations mark the
highest rate by far of a major u.s
airline according to the ap and the
flight tracker flight aware
as for other delays mccarran sent the
message that some flights arriving are
being delayed because of the wind as ted
says the wind will continue to get worse
tonight so expect even more delays going
forward reporting live madison kimbrough
live local now